I I maintained that seduction or
exciting people or persuading them is a
game of absence and presence so if
you're continually present if you're so
obvious if you're always in people's
face you give them no room to use their
imagination to think Oh Robert might be
this very exciting mysterious person
you're so in their face they have no
room to imagine they just see who you
are if you step back and you're not
there so often if instead of being seen
every day you're seeing every other day
or every three days you give space to
the imagination to imagine maybe this
person is actually quite interesting so
you feed other people's imagine you make
them think about you when you're not
there and as they think about you they
start idealizing they start imagining
qualities that maybe aren't there but if
you're too absent if you're there only
once a week for instance then people
might start forgetting about you so you
have to know how to play that game of
back and forth absence and presence
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by Robert Greene I'm sure he
needs no introduction but Robert thank
you very much for coming on I can't wait
to sit down and talk with you today
my pleasure Chris thanks for inviting me
so I have a very lovely story to tell
you actually about one of the guys
behind the modern wisdom project guy
called Jordan who said that your book 48
laws of power was the sole reason that
he studied history at university
apparently apparently somehow tesco big
supermarket in the UK randomly had it on
a shelf he picked it up at the age of 13
and that was the reason he studied
history at the age of 18 so
congratulations stories before that's
always nice to hear thanks yeah it's it
must feel it must feel very I guess
scary to think when you reflect on stuff
like that and realize the sort of impact
that your work has on people well I can
get people to read that you know what
more can I ask you know my my view of
history is that it's not something that
should be thought of as boring something
that's just buried in the past there's
no relevance to today I want to make
history come to life so when you're
reading about Julius Caesar you can feel
what he felt like when he was on the
battlefield when he decided to cross the
Rubicon and you know Pompey so I try to
make history come to life and if readers
feel that way they feel inspired to
study God that's that's the greatest
compliment I could receive well I think
you've you've definitely been paid that
by Jordan so 48 laws of power I'm a
massive fan of what we're talking about
the laws of human nature today which is
your new book as of October last year
that script fantastic so the first
question that way to ask was how how
does this book relate to your past work
48 laws of power art seduction etc etc
well I can't see it as the culmination
sort of the distillation of all that
I've learned over
excuse-me over 20 years of writing books
and doing a lot of consulting work and
just sort of observing people
and I wrote a book prior to this called
mastery and I had a chapter in mastery
about social intelligence and the idea
is that you could be absolutely
brilliant in your field you could know
all the technical things you need to
know but if you're really bad with
people you'll completely neutralize all
of your brilliance you can even be a
genius if you don't know how to work
with people if you irritate and alienate
them then you're gonna be gonna have a
life of misery and pain and I wrote that
chapter this is one element of becoming
a master in your field is being able to
work with people and readers really
responded to that and they said you know
Robert I really like that chapter but I
need more give me more I felt like you
know this is an area where people really
need help you know I needed help when I
was just starting out in the work world
and this kind of this kind of knowledge
you know we live in a world where people
are increasingly self-absorbed they're
just lost in their smartphones whatever
they're not paying attention to people
they're not interacting as much as we
used to interact with people and so
we're losing some basic social skills
the ability to judge people and see
their character and not just simply be
taken in by their appearances so I felt
this was the culmination of all I've
studied and learned over 20-some years
and I'm also trying to meet a really
deep need that people have right now in
the world today I couldn't agree more I
recently interviewed Robin Hanson author
of elephant in the brain and most secret
motives in the way that people behave
was it is a way to expedite your
movement through the world and and avoid
pitfalls I suppose with other people
isn't it so I wanted to I want to kind
of ask something you've already
basically answered which is why is
understanding drives and motivations
important for normal people like you'd
think maybe it's this sort of thing an
evolutionary biologist might be
interested in but how does how does that
relate to the normal layperson
well you know if you want for instance
take a common scenario in life you
either with your children or your boss
or your spouse they have some sort of
irritating behavior it gets on your
nerves and you want to change them you
want to somehow find a way to change
them it's a very common scenario well
the normal thing that most humans do in
that situation is to kind of preach to
tell them look this is what you're doing
it's irritating me you've got to change
or else there's gonna be consequences
you know and we don't realize when we're
in that situation and we talk like that
even if we're being polite that we're
making people defensive we're actually
making the situation worse we're making
it harder to get them to change because
people don't like being told what to do
they don't like being told that they
have to if they're forced to do
something to change themselves and so
when you're in that kind of scenario you
know you have to understand something
basic about human nature you have to
understand that people have an opinion
of themselves they like to think of
themselves as basically good and decent
as basically autonomous that they're in
control of their own lives in their
destiny and that they're basically
intelligent it could be in some if it's
your teenage son it could be he thinks
he's intelligent with video games it
doesn't matter people think they're
intelligent and so you're pushing
against that by telling people what to
do you're making them feel that they
have no control that they're not
autonomous that they have to be forced
in to change their behavior each other
they're not very smart you're making
them feel that they're not a good person
and so all you're doing is making the
situation worse because you don't
understand a very basic principle of
human nature that it's instead of
pushing against what people think about
themselves instead you have to validate
what they think about themselves you
have to make them feel comfortable about
who they are you have to feed their idea
that they are good an autonomous and
intelligent and once you validate and
recognize the other human being you're
dealing with as a human being as an
jool then suddenly there's they're open
to suggestion they're open to change but
because you've worked with some basic
human psychology on and on and on so
constantly in life we're dealing with
hitting against walls with people were
frustrated we're disappointed we can't
get them to change their behavior we
don't know why they're acting this
particular way you know I have a chapter
on envy and I discuss how dangerous envy
is in the world today and how it's like
a it's like a secret gasps nobody admits
that they're envious until you're
suddenly attacked by an envious person
and you find you know something awful is
happening to you nobody comes with a
sign saying I feel Envy I'm attack that
reason right so you have to understand
where Envy comes from why it's a very
basic human emotion why you feel and be
as well and I feel and me and why some
people are toxic in this direction I
could go on and on in all of the
different chapters but your ignorance of
human nature of what motivates human
behavior of why we are simply many of us
are prisoners of things that are wired
into our brain from millions of years
ago is absolutely essential to
navigating these very complicated social
worlds that we inhabit I couldn't agree
more
I have I think that especially the
modern workplace with its serendipitous
Open Office plans and multiple emails
multiple meetings it becomes a petri
dish for these sort of interactions
doesn't it yeah that's a good word
putting it yeah so I wanted to talk
about narcissism it was an interesting
chapter that you touched on I wanted to
ask about whether it's a negative
emotion I think when most people hear
the word narcissism they think
immediately negative emotion no I don't
think anything is negative actually in
the human realm I'm trying to make you
realize that this is part of who we are
as as part of human nature it's not good
or bad it's simply the qualities that we
have and when we look at something like
this is amore envy or aggression it's
partially part of human nature to say
that it's not me I'm not narcissist I'm
not aggressive I don't feel at me it's
always him or her or other people and I
wanted to put hold up a mirror to your
face and say look you are also a
narcissist it is human nature that we
become self-absorbed at a very early age
it's very essential for a child who
feels very vulnerable in an adult world
to develop a degree of self-love so that
they're in situations where you're not
getting enough attention from your
parents attention from your teacher or
your classmates you can withdraw into
yourself and feel that you're actually
good you can withdraw into your own
imagination and sense that there's that
you are worthy of a love and attention
it's a very healthy process to develop a
degree in self-love and what happens is
so I believe everybody has not as
narcissistic to some extent and what you
see in the world is there are people in
early childhood who never develop that
kind of self-love that anchor inside of
themselves they can't get a feeling of
being a good person of being a valid
validated from within it has to come
from outside so they spend their whole
lives trying to get attention from other
people and that's what a deep narcissist
is you know a classic example is
President of the United States never
feels satisfied from within from the
attention that he's getting so he
constantly has to act out and get other
people to validate who he is so deep
narcissists are incredibly insecure and
the only way they can get they can kind
of get over that feeling is to get
attention is to be extremely dramatic
and the problem that happens is a lot of
times people like that are very
brilliant they're very charismatic they
learn as children to be very dramatic
and have a flair and get a lot of
attention that way and it's
you get in a relationship with them
either as an intimate partner or they
become your boss or they're your calling
it's only after months and months that
you realize this person doesn't care
about me at all they only see me as an
object that they can use to sort of feed
their narcissism so I want you to
recognize that there's a spectrum that
at a certain point like let's say with
zero to a hundred and at the halfway
point fifty is where most of us are we
have a degree of self absorption and
when we feel comfortable about ourselves
and we're not insecure we rise slowly
above that level and get up to 75 or 80
and as we get higher and we feel
comfortable we can get outside of
ourselves and pay attention to other
people and transform that self-love that
we have a narcissism into actual empathy
but if we fall below that 50 percent
mark we get lower and lower and lower
and we've all been through moments like
that moments of depression etc we become
more and more self-absorbed becomes very
hard to get outside of ourselves and get
into the skin of other people and that's
what happens to deep narcissists they
can never rise above and get outside of
themselves and they're actually quite
miserable so I want to take away the
judgment that narcissism is necessarily
a bad thing I call it a call it healthy
narcissism so there are two forms of
taking that sort of self-love that we
have been turning into something healthy
that's getting outside of ourselves
either into other people putting our
attention to other people and caring
about them and getting inside their
world or into our work and pouring all
of our energy into our work so you'll
notice a lot of great artists even
scientist cetera can actually very be
very narcissistic but they pour a lot of
their energy into their work and they're
able to kind of transmute or transform
that that ugly energy into something
positive so there's nothing wrong with
being a narcissist we all have that
degree of self-love is whether we become
so
self-absorbed that we can't get out of
our own little prison I totally agree
I'm sure that a lot of the listeners
will be able to think of people in their
lives who are constantly searching for
attention who can't find that sense of
self-worth from within themselves is
there any strategies that you can
recommend for someone who is around
another person who is like that for
potentially the the First Lady of the
United States well it's very difficult I
mean really often the best strategy of
all is to learn about how to recognize
the deep narcissists because as I said
before they don't go around the sign
saying I'm a deep narcissist
no watch out they can be very charming
and charismatic and so you want to look
for signs early on that they're not
really paying attention to you while
some of those signs well you'll notice
that they're though when you talk about
yourself they seem to be listening but
they're not really listening their eyes
are kind of dead they don't really
engage with you they're not really
interested in your ideas and who you are
they give it kind of a service
impression that they are but it's a so
sometimes with the deep narcissist
you'll notice on their facial
expressions that they'll be smiling a
lot as they listen to you and nodding
their head but there's deadness in their
eyes they're not really engaged with you
they're not really the eyes reveal a lot
about how deeply people are looking at
you and interested and engaged and
there's a kind of Sheen there they're
not paying really attention to you
they're not interested in your ideas
look at their past and their broken
record of how many people they've
alienated and how they can't stay very
long in a relationship see the patterns
of that but most of all notice that
people who are extra dramatic who even
seem charismatic
they tend to be narcissus learn how to
charm you to get the attention that they
need it's called the the narcissistic
feed they might be begging to be fed all
the time and so they're always searching
for that attention so be able to look at
people like that from a distance if you
know someone who's extremely dramatic
like that and you find it interesting
perhaps you're in tennis you go off and
think maybe all of that drama and all of
that excitement that they generate is
just to get attention as nothing to do
with you so sort of look for the signs
beforehand and so the best strategy is
to not get involved if that strategy is
to avoid them at all costs it is you
know most of us have degrees of
narcissism and we should be empathetic
to that and you can draw people out by
getting them involved in a relationship
or getting them interested in your life
or if you have a child that you suspect
might have that tendency getting them to
become extremely excited by some feel
some works and objects something they
can study to get outside of their
self-absorption but with someone who's
an adult who's has these tendencies
you're not really ever going to change
them so the best strategy is either to
not avoid a relationship or to somehow
manage it so that they're not kind of
destroying your life one of the points
that you touched on there which I found
very useful and very interesting was
curiosity and what someone else is
saying as being a useful strategy for
bonding and for making people feel like
the conversations going in the right
direction listeners may remember a
recent conversation I had with David
Parral where he spoke about most
conversations being two intersecting
monologues almost like a game of tennis
and as a solution to not coming across
as too self-absorbed genuine curiosity
like actually caring about what the
other person is saying and genuinely
wanting to know what they think about
things appears to be a really good
rough-hewn antidote
- - that yes very much so I mean it's
kind of a cliched to say that people
don't listen well and you just need to
become a better listener and I don't
think that's gonna really change
people's behavior the problem why you're
not really listening to other people in
a conversation while that kind of tennis
game of monologues of two monologues
going on is because you're not really
that interested in what the other person
has to say you find your own problems
your own life your own interests more
fascinating than what they have to say
you're worried about you know your what
you can do tomorrow of whether this
woman is interested in you or not
you're absorbing your own anxieties and
problems and what people are talking
about aren't as interesting to you so
the only solution is to somehow get
yourself to a place and realize that the
people you deal with are actually very
interesting they're fascinating you want
to understand them they're weirder than
you imagine people are weird they have
strange dreams just like you have
strange dreams right yeah we watch
movies because we're fascinated by the
characters and we want to get inside
what's motivating that evil person in
that movie why is that person a kid a
murderer etc we want to get inside their
worlds were fascinated by characters in
the movie well the people you're dealing
with on a day-to-day basis are like
characters in a movie
they have Deb's that you can even begun
to see or suspect they have fantasies
they have a dark side they have a shadow
side that they're trying to hide so if
you approach life like it's theater like
it's just all like a movie and that
people are interesting and you want to
figure out who they are it suddenly
changes the game so that when you're
sitting down tomorrow now with that
friend we've had endless boring
conversations with nope never listening
to them if suddenly you stop that and
you actually stopped your interior
monologue and you paid attention and you
looked at their body language
and you looked at the way their eyes
shivved as they're talking about
something or how their eyes light up
when a certain subject is touched if you
suddenly stop and really pay attention
you're gonna learn things and it's going
to be fascinating and you're gonna be
able to apply that knowledge in many
many ways but none of this all of my
talk all of my books all the books ever
written won't matter at all if you don't
find people inherently interesting yeah
I think there's some people in your life
that you have to put up with the
conversations with like you're not gonna
stop speaking to Grandma like when she
wants to come round but there's a
there's an upper bound on how far you
can take that but yeah definitely
especially my experience having done
this podcast and you know recording to
three hours of deep conversations every
week for a year I've certainly noticed
in myself that that instantiation of
genuinely being interested in a normal
guest is now bleeding into my discourse
day-to-day with other people and that's
making my conversations with other
people so much more interesting than
they ever were before but I've not
become any more interesting well maybe a
tiny bit but obviously after speaking to
you Robert I'll be an awful lot rusty
but yeah I'm not that much more
interesting but I'm more interested in
what they have to say which elicits a
better response from them which raises
the the level of the conversation up but
yeah I totally agree I wanted to move on
to some of my favorite stories from the
book and I wanted to ask why Bill
Clinton was a successful politician and
how this relates to wearing masks that's
strange because I took that's what story
you're referring to the IRA story the
one where he was talking about why how
bill was able to curate himself and his
accent towards different audiences okay
well he was you know Bill Clinton was
kind of a master actor and I have
nothing against people being actors in
life in fact I'd say it's essential we
are all actors were all performing some
of us are good actors and some of us are
bad actors
but when you're in interacting with your
boss you're not the same person as you
are when you're interacting with your
intimate partner you change you put on a
different mask you change your body
language the way you talk we do that
with everybody that we deal with and so
people who are really good at this game
who get far who have a high level of
social skill know how to kind of blend
in to the audience to the people that
they're dealing with they can sometimes
you know change their accent a little
bit like he would do he you know if he
wanted to keep talking to a working
class group he would kind of you know
emphasize his own working-class Southern
roots but he was talking to a group of
intellectuals he would kind of soften
his southern accent a bit not a lot of
people find that false and manipulative
I don't I think being able to adapt to
the people that you're dealing with is a
high level of social skill because what
it means is you're thinking about who
that audience is about were the people
you're dealing with and you're trying to
get into their spirit and you're not
just simply looking at them as something
from a distance like objects that you
manipulate you know to win an election
you actually care about them and you're
getting into their world and into their
mindset and so I want to take away the
guilt that we humans have for who we
really are
that's the main theme in all of my books
we're so goddamned guilty about the
desires that we want for power for
instance that was the subject of the 48
laws of power and we're self we feel so
guilty about this idea that we might be
manipulated that we might be actors as
if we're being fake or inauthentic it's
just a lot of [ __ ] in my mind
because we are all acting all of the
time look at yourself in your day to day
interactions you change your mask you
change your expression your words
depending on who you're dealing with
you never tell people damage you put on
40 pounds you're not looking
see no you look great today Wow you know
I left your screenplay it was great you
don't tell them the truth just did you
do that and stop being this kind of fake
Saint that everybody's trying to pose
like they are so I applaud someone like
a Bill Clinton who knows how to be a
consummate actor and change according to
who he's talking to
why do you think we are so guilty about
our natural human nature's is that
because we are only exposed to the
highlight reel of other people so the
sort of the darker depths of them is
never really shown with that same degree
of fidelity that we get to see our own
kind of biases at work and our our
darker parts well you know I was a few
years ago I was in Sydney Australia and
I went to the zoo there and I was kind
of transfixed by the chimpanzee compound
that they have the Sydney zoo it's
amazing this is very open space where
you can observe an entire community of
about 30 chimpanzees and what shocked me
more than anything I was sat there for
two hours watching them he wasn't so
human it was just like looking at an
office situation with the alpha male and
all the others kind of but what was
equally fascinating was all the young
people who would stop by and they were
very embarrassed by looking into
chimpanzees they were giggling they were
made uncomfortable about it and my the
point I'm making is I think we feel
uncomfortable about our own animal
nature about our own primate roots about
the primitive part of ourselves we want
to think of ourselves Angela Carter the
English writer she said we like to think
that were descended from angels instead
of primates you know but we are
descended from primates and primates
have tendencies that are embedded in us
our tendency to feel Envy our own
aggressive impulses these are things
that come from millions of years of
evolution but were uncomfortable with it
we want to think of ourselves as these
sort of 21st century incredibly
sophisticated people that we don't have
these sort of dark animal-like impulses
but just spend a
weeks on social media on the Internet
and you see that primate part of our
nature is out there in full display even
though it's the most sophisticated tool
of communication ever invented yeah
you'll ever see so many displays of envy
as on social media you know envy was a
terrible problem among hunter-gatherer
cultures hundreds of thousands of years
ago wise people people would be murdered
because you had a little group of 30
people your clan your tribe and if some
people felt Envy that others had more
food or more wealth or more goods they
would get very angry and they would
murder someone for that and so because
we're the human brain is always
comparing ourselves to other people
our brains operate by a comparing
mechanism it's how we learn and we're
also because we're social animals were
also comparing ourselves to what other
people have
so hunter-gatherer tribes it was a
terrible problem and that's why they
invented all kinds of rituals so the
moment you received a gift you had to
share it with everyone else or give it
away you never felt comfortable and you
received more than other people at
because you knew that was dangerous
you had to give it away but here we are
hundreds of thousands of years later and
envy is even worse than it was I was
still suffering the artifact of a
quarter of a million years ago yes so
we're no more sophisticated in so many
ways than we were but we don't like to
confront that I think a lot of people
would do so well to read a tiny bit of
evolutionary biology evolutionary
psychology that needs to be I've been
thinking about this for a while there
needs to be like a 10 page booklet cheat
sheet with big pictures that's just like
the absolute 82 out like the 99 to 1 of
exactly what people need to know and
you're totally right the more educated
you become about these biases and why we
feel the way we do people accept
sensations like envy as this sort of
emergent property that's just a law of
the
the same way that gravity is where is it
it's it's not it is this artifact of a
time gone by where we needed it and we
don't now but with somehow still its
mercy I find it I find it so fascinating
so I've really enjoyed getting into
learning about it recently yeah I mean
another aspect that's similar to that is
our asked it going to the evolutionary
biology part is hmm before the invention
of language we as a social animal our
survival depended on our ability to
communicate with the group and so we
humans developed complex emotions more
emotions than other animals have that
could be displayed on our face and our
body language that would communicate to
people so if we felt fear about a
situation we would have you know
chimpanzees and other animals have the
hair stand on the back of their neck we
had many more ways of signaling fear and
this would communicate itself to the
entire group and the whole group would
feel that fear and they would know we
better run away you know there get out
of the situation but other other
emotions like joy etc so the group we
were primed evolutionarily to feel the
emotions of the group to be susceptible
and vulnerable to what other people are
feeling as a form of communication in
survival well fast forward to hundreds
of thousands of years later and that
kind of viral susceptibility that we
have to the emotions and ideas of other
people is in full display on social
media in our politics etc we're
extremely susceptible to the moods and
ideas and opinions of other people we
like to think well I'm I'm you know I'm
left-wing I have all my deals on my own
I nobody ever told me
but you'll notice it that if they
explain their ideas they're just exactly
the same as thousands of other people
why do they share all of the same ideas
about the same subject as thousands of
other people it's because they're
conforming to the group it's because
you're susceptible to that pressure to
feel like you're fitting into the group
and you're very vulnerable to what other
people are saying and doing we're
constantly imitating and we're
constantly being influenced by people
and not realizing it so that's just
another aspect of how something very
ancient that served a purpose for our
ancestors is now something that doesn't
serve so well for us in the modern age
yeah I think people being very careful
about the circles that they expose
themselves to online is an incredibly
useful tool I think I went onto your
Twitter earlier on am i right in saying
that you follow sixty-eight people on
Twitter or a very low number of people
yes yes oh I'm I'm on 66 which is and
I've found it very interesting to see
that you've done the same and I'm going
to presume that it is because your
newsfeed is to be curated to only see
things that you want to see yeah but you
know you take that too far because you
know you do sort of want to expose
yourself to what other people are saying
and thinking you know so you do want to
not just read the same blogs and the
same podcasts that confirm what you
already believe echo-chamber effects
dangerous yeah so sometimes it's good to
expose yourself to what Trump supporters
are saying on the Internet I find that
fascinating I don't I don't demonize
them because they are human beings I do
want to understand why they have fallen
to the spell of this madman so it's good
to like not just consume the ideas that
support and confirm what you already
believe but also you're right you do
have to regulate it as well because
those that anger that you can feel when
you read something so frustrating and
irritating can ruin your whole day it's
so it blows my mind so the listeners own
will know mine and the team's personal
feelings with regards to notifications
on phones but if you are listening to
this perhaps for the first time because
you've seen that we've got rubber on I'm
going to sing the song to you right now
which is please go on to your iPhone
settings or Android or whatever you're
using and just turn off the
notifications on your social media check
them at your will
not at the will of the of the machine
that's in your pocket because this sort
of unscheduled dopamine release that
were at the mercy of throughout the day
I mean it must especially for you Robert
as someone who's been understanding
human nature for such a long time
presumably before the advent of
smartphone social media and then seeing
I guess all of these human
characteristics that you've known for so
long get like amplified and then
broadcast to the world it must have been
a very interesting a fascinating sort of
experiment and also terrifying I'm going
to freak if you read books by marketing
people and the psychology of marketing
you'll understand how insidious that can
be these are people who study psychology
more than anybody else who understand
why how the human brain works and how to
pass information along without giving
the appearance that you're giving people
news how to be so sneaky with how you
can influence human behavior and you
better believe that Mark Zuckerberg the
founder of Facebook has studied in depth
all of these marketing tools and has
applied them to a great degree on
Facebook so just the idea of that
pinging noise of creating a noise like
like for a child that kind of has a
dopamine effect that you have on and on
and on they know they know completely
all the viral effects that they can
create it's the reason why the badge
color is red because red is a high alert
color right right exactly so you're
we're all just being dupes of a great
marketing team of people who know how to
feed upon the vulnerabilities in human
nature you know and I read a book a
while ago a French book I don't know how
to translate the timeless has to do
about a guide how to manipulate people
is basically what it's called hims
written by two social scientists in
France who revealed all of the tricks
that marketing people all of the studies
that they use you know in in
universities around the world psychology
department
are doing studies about human behavior
where they actually do experiments with
people the number one audience for
reading those studies are people in
marketing so they know for instance they
knew about virtue of signaling well
before we ever heard about it they know
that people like to share the fact
they're giving to causes you look on
Facebook and you see all that time for
your birthday I want to contribute you
know fifteen hundred dollars to the save
the gorilla fund or whatever they know
this is a supreme marketing skill that
people want to signal to others you know
so it increases their look how many
people look at it how how much traffic
they have so don't be naive about social
media these people are geniuses evil
geniuses but everybody that's listening
just unfollow everyone from Twitter then
go follow myself and Robert and then
slowly begin to build it back up
obviously you need us to first and once
you've got us to you can start to build
it up from there I don't know just a
book and that I don't know if you're
familiar with Tristan Harris from the
Center for Humane Technology so he used
to be the design ethicist at Google and
has now he is the equivalent of like an
Edward Snowden for social media I need
Chris Dan Harris I'll send you it once
we're done and I'll link it in the show
notes below to anyone who is interested
his podcast with Sam Harris no relation
is mind-blowing unbelievable about the
the psychology of persuasion and all of
the different tactics that are being
used I think you're gonna find it
fascinating thank you very much really
good so I wanted to talk moving on to
things that are interesting I wanted you
to try and explain why mystery is
seductive why mysterious attack mystery
in another person I thought like why
does they need to be explained
it's so obvious to me well it was it was
news to me when it happened I it's
something that when it's explained to
you they say the best books are ones
that tell you something you already know
right it was something that
implicitly I may be new but explicitly I
don't think I've thought of before well
it's the whole reason why we're
interested in stories in drama in films
and theater in plays and anything having
to do with fiction is we don't know
what's happening next so there's an
element of surprise
what does a writer have in mind what are
we going to read about next that happens
to this character and so I related to
when were a child and we're being Anna
our father for instance picks us up and
carries us and twirls us around we don't
know where he's taking us he doesn't we
don't know where it's going to we were
on a ride at an amusement park
the excitement is whoa what's gonna
happen next so we're inherently we're
primed for surprises we want surprise we
want drama
we want this feeling it's a mixture of
anxiety and pleasure like we're anxious
like is the murderer right behind that
door is he gonna come in now and kill
someone oh he is and so it's like
pleasure that we anticipated it and so
we're the sense of mystery comes from we
don't know exactly what's going to
happen and so the opposite of mystery is
complete familiarity is banality so if
you're in a relationship with someone
and you know everything about them
there's no surprises left everything has
you've seen everything that's going here
everybody to see it's always the same
some people might say well that's that's
a really good marriage that makes that
makes for a very good relationship well
no it's not because the human brain
needs a sense of there's something I
don't know about them I have to discover
something it's what actually kills a lot
of relationships that people become too
familiar with each other they stop
seducing this there there's nothing left
to learn about someone we want to feel
like we can learn something that there
are surprises but there is mystery and
so I I maintain that seduction or
exciting people or persuading them is a
game of absence and presence so if
you're continually present if you're so
obvious if you're always in people's
face you give them no room to use their
imagination to think Oh Robert might be
this very exciting mysterious person
you're so in their face they have no
room to imagine they just see who you
are if you step back and you're not
there so often if instead of being seen
every day you're seeing every other day
or every three days you give space to
the imagination to imagine maybe this
person is actually quite interesting so
you feed other people's imagine you make
them think about you when you're not
there and as they think about you they
start idealizing they start imagining
qualities that maybe aren't there but if
you're too absent if you're there only
once a week for instance then people
might start forgetting about you so you
have to know how to play that game of
back and forth absence in presence we
had a discussion on a relationships
episode that we do which is a series we
have ongoing at the moment which
discussed the fine art of when it's
right to text someone after the first
day and then how frequently to do it
thereafter and you are totally correct
that there is this this spectrum where
there's a Goldilocks zone that appears
somewhere in the middle and for some
people they may be shifted right down to
the bottom and for some they may be
right up to the top there's a video from
Alain de Botton who runs the School of
Life YouTube channel unbelievable anyone
who hasn't watched it already
I implore you to go and have a look
because there is some wisdom drops of
five minutes on there however he does a
video which is why we dislike people who
like us and he talks about how people
that are very forthcoming it feeds into
our own self sort of worry and
self-hatred and insecurities about the
fact that well why are they liking me
there's something wrong with me they
shouldn't like me therefore there must
be something wrong with them so I'm
going to known this this this isn't for
me um
we chase after the person who doesn't
give us any attention it's it's so it's
so hilarious
yeah and that's often why narcissists
can be very seductive and charismatic
because they're not that interested in
you and we want to be the one that makes
us chase after them we want to get them
to be interested in us we want to get
their attention sometimes so you know
that's very known phenomenon but you
know the idea that the number one law of
human nature of psychology that you must
understand is particularly when it comes
to persuasion and influence is that
people want to have their will powers
engaged they want to feel like they're
the ones who were active that they are
doing something that's why in marketing
and in advertisements if you bombard
people with information they know it's
an ad and they don't care and they don't
listen they tune it out but if you
create a viral effect where everyone is
talking about this particular product
then you no longer feel that you're the
do bit of an advertising you feel like
that you've come to it through your own
decision because other people talk to
you about it and now you go out and buy
it because you feel like you're it's you
who's doing it you're being active so we
like to feel that we are active and when
a person whose mysterious who has a step
back is our imagination is active we get
to think about who they are we get to
imagine that there's somebody great and
you know that element is extremely
powerful as opposed to be told who they
are by constantly being in our face
that's a fantastic point I suppose
influence the marketing now with the
advent of social media is increasingly
trying to make more and more subtle
these steps that we take to get us to
this recommendation for a product and
yeah I wonder where the future of that
lies I wonder how much more subtle and
subversive the the tactics can get we're
just getting a riff on social media try
to stop the podcast right we're just
gonna
playing about safe for the rest of it
well I'm subliminal advertising which
was the big subject back in the 60s when
people would put in one frame of a soft
drink and a movie and see that people
you know pass so quickly you couldn't
realize it then everybody at the
intermission would go buy a coca-cola
you know that got joked about because
you know nobody does that it's illegal
in fact to do that in the United States
but subliminal advertising using
subliminal effects is extremely powerful
and it's at the level of what you do for
an infant so people know that certain
sounds have a certain effect movies are
now designed by sound designers who know
how not to use music but how to create
that continual drone that's going to
have the precise effect of creating
horror and anxiety or raising they are
masters at manipulating you want a
subliminal level that's the future
that's the scary matrix future that we
have but hopefully we can control and
not get into it if you know so well how
to affect people subliminally on that
infant level of oh there's a mobile up
here I want to touch you play with those
pretty little things yeah that's how
they operate that's very powerful and
very insidious yeah it really is one of
the chapters that I really really
resonated with me I'm working Club promo
so I run night clubs as a part of that
I'm exposed to a very high velocity wide
range of personality types and the toxic
types of people that you identified
particularly the big talker and the
drama magnet as I'm sure you can imagine
working in nightlife they really really
resonated with me I wondered if he might
be able to just chill rifle I sure
should honestly the observations of
human behavior in nightclubs is a feel
like I should be an anthropologist just
sat on the front door observing what
happens and
see look I'm telling you well maybe
maybe that might be that might be the
next step but yes I wanted to just ask
yourself about what toxic types of
people you have seen consistently in
your life
the ones that swim in the academic
circles perhaps or the ones who you
think that are more common to yourself I
would be interested to find that yeah I
know there's a lot of academic people
intellectuals they're very aggressive
but they put all of their aggression
into argument into a certain style of
arguing and they're masters at putting
you down so I you know I get a lot of
grief for writing the 48 laws of power
for being kind of manipulative for being
for riding a popular best-selling book
and it's not you know not very weighty
enough for them and so people who are
intellectuals have very subtle ways of
putting you down you know of saying WOW
Robert I see that your book has sold
very well amongst people on Wall Street
you know so there's complimenting you
that your book is selling well but
they're also dissing you for the fact
that you're appealing to two sharks out
there you know so the subtle put-down
the kind of disguises Envy I get a lot
from people who are academic
intellectual types you know I I found I
do a lot of consulting work with people
who are high level in business and I was
on the board of directors of a publicly
traded company and when I talk about a
narcissist the kind of a toxic deep
narcissist believe me I know what I'm
talking about because I've dealt with
them on a very person to person level so
the CEO that I was working with it was
head of this company I was on the board
of directors he was very charismatic
very dramatic and I was seduced by him I
fell for him I thought
this guy is brilliant he's a genius and
as only as evidence piled up as I tried
to give him advice and I tried to tell
him the company's heading downward
quickly you need to do this this and
this and I realize he wouldn't listen to
anything I said even though he hired me
for my brilliant 48 laws of power advice
so you know there's a lot of people you
know like an Elon Musk have this kind of
quality where they attract a lot of
followers and they seem so exciting and
interesting but they're actually
disguising a lot of deep-rooted
emotional problems and the person in the
laws of human nature that really
resonates with me on that level is the
story of Howard Hughes whom you didn't
read that part I must have missed up it
please tell us
well not he Howard Hughes as you know
was the great they did the film without
him he's the great aviator who started
you know animating a very important
airline company manufacturing airplanes
Hughes Aircraft and he had this
reputation for being this incredible
maverick for being someone who would fly
a plane and risk death and do all sorts
of crazy things and so he got this
reputation and people thought this is
he's like an American icon we venerate
him and he started this business this
airline company and he if you add up the
number of failures that he had in
business he has to be probably the worst
businessman that ever lived he lost more
money than anybody that I can think of
in history through various ventures on
and on and on he's the army commissions
him to build this herb his new airplane
he can't he can't do it he can't bring
it to pass he creates one of the largest
plane ever invented if you saw the movie
you saw it but I can't fly anywhere it
can't do anything there's only one of
them it was never used he had other
Commission's like that he was an
incredible failure but time and again
people
funded him and supported him because
they fell for this belief in the myth
about how great he was and a lot of what
happens to people is I talk in the book
about grandiosity when you have success
like he had her you get attention like
that you think that you're a god you
think that you're infallible and no
matter what you create or produce is
going to be you know absolutely perfect
and so you kind of believe in your own
myth that's a very big time sort of
toxic type that I've met in my
consulting work the people in business
they've had some success and I think
that nothing they can do is wrong so
they don't listen to anybody and they
feel like they can control everything
kind of micromanager type of profile
that's one toxic type I've I could go on
and on I'm sure you could I did want to
ask a question actually that Sam Harris
asked Daniel Kahneman when they did a
podcast recently and he said how much of
your writing is advice for yourself
versus for others and does the
understanding of these laws help your
behavior when Sam asked Dan Kahneman
this he said I he's not he's no better
at avoiding his own biases just more
cognizant when it happened was and more
regretful after the fact have fun it's
so hilarious well that's true I mean I
can see that but I'm a little more
hopeful that maybe Dan Kahneman is I
think that if you recognize your own
biases it gives you a degree of control
over them so I I say that when we humans
aren't rational that were basically
driven by our emotions which is
something that he talks a lot about they
called the effect of heuristic that when
people buy economic behavior is not
driven by rationality it's driven more
by emotions and so you know I have these
biases obviously as well so when I'm
running the book on human nature I have
a bias which is I have a negative bias I
tend to view people from it through a
negative
I don't think we're so great as we think
we are I think we're more violent and
aggressive than we want to admit so it's
a bias of mine and the tendency is to go
read books that confirm that bias and so
I've deliberately made a point of being
aware of that and so the percentage of
books that I read probably were weighted
for sure on the negative side I can't
help this 60 70 percent weren't on the
negative side but I overcame my bias to
some degree in order to include books by
like Steven Pinker whom I hate like and
stand his books but I read them sort of
forced myself like our better angels you
know yeah and enlightenment now whatever
yeah I read his books you know he's a
very important thinker he's he's
brilliant he's you know Harvard and all
that just to balance out my own biases
but you know it's a margin there you're
never as he as Dan Kammen saying you can
never really completely overcome those
biases that you have because they're
built into you it's but if you can
recognize them change you can open your
mind a little bit of some information
that won't necessarily confirm what you
are already looking for so my books have
helped me in that sense of when I wrote
the book I sort of had to come to
certain realizations number one I had to
realize I'm not as great a person as I
thought I was I'm actually more of a
narcissist than I imagined
I'm actually running at a chapter on
aggression was a real eye-opener to me
because I go well Robert you are
actually a very aggressive person you
manage to disguise that people think
you're so nice and polite but you're
actually deep down very aggressive and
it was kind of painful for me but coming
to terms with these sort of qualities
that I have have made me sort of more
aware of how I'm operating in the social
realm so that I can control it better so
I disagree a little bit with them it has
given me not complete control but more
self-awareness I think finding out
things about you
through learning concepts and these sort
of biases is one of the most rewarding
things that I've done through my sort of
self-directed learning reading both
reading books like yours and Danny
Kahneman's and Robin Hansen's and it
it's like discovering a treasure that
sort of inside of you and has always
been there and some of sometimes they're
terrifying and sometimes they're
embarrassing or things that you don't
like but they're never not fascinating
we touched on Alain de Botton from the
school of life earlier on he has a video
that the listeners will be familiar with
which I love which is called why we are
fated to be lonely and he talks about
how people whose views a more alarming
contrary or subtle to society at large
by their very nature likely to be out on
the tales of the normal distribution of
normal whatever normal is and he says
loneliness is a kind of tax that we have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind and I just wanted to get your
thoughts on that brief little little
thought from away now I always wanted to
ask you what your thoughts are on
people's uniqueness and their disability
to be categorized into tropes or these
archetypal roles I guess even Jordan
Peterson would say about what your
thoughts are on that and what their
usefulness or that potential pitfalls
are for people are you asking me whether
I'm lonely or not well yeah I mean you
know you there's a price that you pay
for trying to be more of who you are and
being more of yourself and for not
fitting into categories but I don't know
if I completely agree it's hard for me
to completely align it with my own
experience so I've felt from barrier
I don't like talking about myself so
much but I'll just bring this up I
always thought that I was sort of
strange not like other people and I
imagine most alot of people have that
feeling as well but you know so when it
came to like making creating something
or writing a book which was my first
book the 48 laws of power I was able to
sort of keep true to myself to keep true
to house my own strange way of thinking
and so I created a book that's not like
anything you've ever seen before
physically it doesn't look like a normal
book inside the way it's designed that's
all a reflection of my own strangeness
of my own weirdness but that's precisely
what made the book stand out and what's
made it interesting so on the one hand
you know there is a little bit of
loneliness in the sense that I don't fit
into easy categories me it's beginning
myself I'm not an academic I'm not I
don't have a PhD but I'm not purely a
self-help book writer I'm not a coach
I'm not a guru I don't know what
category do I fit in and so you know
people are a little bit they don't know
how to approach me but I have to say
that the attention I've gotten from
sticking to being myself I'm sticking to
my own weirdness to putting out ideas
that are kind of strange to a lot of
people and not worrying about it has
been the source of a lot of social
attention and social validation I was
actually a lot lonelier
before I wrote these books and before I
had the acclaim I couldn't connect to
people I felt like I had something
strange to say but no one would listen
to me at all so in some sense I always
preached people to people if you want to
create something that's interesting in
that last and that is meaningful kind of
stage FRU - what makes you different to
what you know is that quality that Alain
de Botton say is gonna make you lonely
in some ways it's sort of the source of
your power it's the way I think people
are
agree in the world for something new for
some kind of new form of communication
from people who are coming from a
different angle and it's a source of
power and yet it brings loneliness but
loneliness happens anyway would have
happened anyway you know I've always had
that degree of being alone and kind of
well I actually like being alone I like
being able to have be away from the
crowd or to have my distance in space so
that's just my slight little take on
what you said I told you get it I think
you have two choices when you're talking
about how you how you view loneliness or
how you view solitude I suppose and on
one hand like you say you can have
honesty or acceptability and on the side
of honesty you have the virtue you have
creations of work like yours or for me
at the moment it's currently this
podcast it's me talking and being
unashamed about the things that I'm
interested in whether it whether it does
or does not fit the heritage or the mold
that I'm supposed to have again to give
you a very brief bit of background I did
some reality TV stuff it would be the
equivalent of The Bachelor I guess in in
the US and that kind of archetypal role
that going and doing a podcast based in
interviewing very successful and
interesting authors and talking about
the finer points of human nature
probably doesn't really fit but you're
totally right you can have the choice of
being lonely and truthful to yourself or
lonely and compromising yourself
absolutely um that's a really lovely
point but one thing I say is loneliness
is not a bad thing I mean it can get
depressing but it also gives you the
space to kind of step away from the
crowd and think for yourself and think
about your own tastes and your own
values and what you want to say in life
so a lot of times people have a hard
time these days being alone they always
have to be surrounded by something
that's you
attention to their phone door whatever
but creating that space where you can
reflect and have some distance from the
world I think is very powerful and
important absolutely anyone who is
listening there's a very interesting
definition of solitude which Cal Newport
used from digital minimalism and it's a
different one to what most people will
consider a lot of people may think I
spend time on my own and maybe drive
drive a lot or I work from home as I do
I work from home but Cal's definition of
solitude which he says is important for
us to develop particular qualities of
mind he defines it as time for your mind
to be away from the input of other minds
that's very different solitude in that
way is different to what most people
would consider when the phone still on
an email still on or there you know I
think that that distinction and the time
that you can spend alone with your
thoughts reflecting on the day or your
bigger picture I think is is very
important I agree Robert I've absolutely
loved today I I know that your books
take a very long time to write but I
really hope that you hasten the next one
along because what this sit down with
you and talk again okay you know it's
time before the next book comes up
because these books sometimes take
several years so you just let me know
fantastic for the listeners at home can
you tell them where they can find you
online and where they can look to find
some more resources or some more info
well the main site is my old website
which is power seduction and war calm
those the titles of my first three books
excuse me power seduction the word Anne
spelled out and war calm and there
you'll find links to the book I did a
motor book with fifty Cent called the
50th law my book mastery and my new book
the laws of human nature and links to
the Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
and all the stuff that we were yelling
about earlier all that evil social media
stuff that I
was described but I still participated
we have to play the game we have to play
no yeah I know
absolutely Robert I really appreciate
your time I can't thank you enough for
coming on in our I'm afraid that I'm
probably going to hassle you for that
before the next book podcasts invite the
Eve extended my way and I'm sure that
the listeners are gonna want it as well
yeah very much enjoy it thank you so
much your great style great podcasting
style thank you that's really really
time to work in the background what's
that
what's the shark a shark oh yeah do you
wanna see him or something I'm afraid
I'm afraid it's not a symbolic shark it
doesn't mean anything more than the fact
that my black bedding without a fluffy
animal on it looks a little bit kind of
dull so it's decided to put a shark on
it
yeah all right that's right sometimes a
cigar is just a cigar and on that we're
going to end Robert thank you so much
thanks a lot Chris my pleasure
[Music]
you